a number of pretty major game reviewers
and game reviewing Outlets have not
received review codes for full spoken to
a lot of you this probably doesn't mean
anything but generally if review cards
aren't given out for AAA game it tends
to mean that they aren't confident in
how reviews are going to perform and
thus often foreshadows the game not
being very good it's a sort of effective
way of guessing how a review is going to
turn out with actually seeing the
reviews themselves I'm sourcing emo
posts for this article who put together
a bunch of different Outlets that have
not received codes including VGC Windows
Central is also included and skill-up
friend of the show scallop also said I
also haven't heard of any Outlet having
access to PC code yet but can't confirm
this and I've had the same thing I do
not know anyone who has access to a PC
code for the game just yet we don't have
to wait long for reviews though anyway
the Embargo is Monday and the game comes
out on Tuesday